[Music]
should I simply give up on my sister
because she's frail I refuse to accept
that I'll wipe out that sort of world
myself
the world is destined to descend into
greater chaos so do you feel better
after your little walk not really but I
don't care anymore even if I did it's
not like I have any choice I'm a Navy
pilot now nothing else that's not how it
feels but it isn't like that
yes it is
where haven't you read the headlines the
people who vote
we're human in the same sense that they
are
there is no such thing as coincidence
everything happens one more time with
all the power of Japan behind you
[Music]
our lives along with the lives of every
creature on this planet
I've got to go I don't see you but you
will be
[Music]
ever
perfect hallo
called her
you have been most useful - I can't
I am forever grateful
for sky
to our customer
[Applause]
innocent
[Music]
I'll protect you
go
you are now a hurricane
the perfect halo
I've called her
but you off against the plow that's my
stance
just for a minute
before sky
let you up like a star that our Father
and now it's found us
like I have found you just overwhelm me
I destroy the world
[Music]
and create it